mit ihrem einsatz belegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
digitaler kunst für 17 millionen dollar
eine spekulationswelle oder eine
revolution im kunstmarkt die künstlerin
zilla leutenegger zeichnet mit räumen
ihre biografie wie das geht jetzt in
kultur platz
[Musik]
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz ja heute
machen wir station hier im bündner
kunstmuseum in chur und hier begegnen
wir gleich zähler zilla leutenegger 1968
geboren hier in chur erzählt in ihrer
großen werkschau von kindheit von jugend
von inneren und von äußeren räumen und
auch vom wilden tier in uns allen
[Musik]
in ihrer ausstellung nimmt uns zähler
leutenecker mit an orte vergangener tage
es ist sinnlos welt und wie die eigenen
vier wände
über die jahre hinweg eine geschichte
erzählen
eine gezeichnete biografie anhand von
räumen und erlebten erinnerungen
[Musik]
die news telekom jetzt arg sind ist ja
voll corona konzipiert wurde
und doch hat man das gefühl dass ich
glaube weg das ist eine antwort auf das
jahr vor der pandemie virus alle ihre
zurückzogen hand wieso sind eigentlich
röser zentral für die erinnerung man
kann sich rühmt europa in dem sich drei
erinnert dass landwehr und aldi ort wo
wir konnten und wo wichtig sind warum
man heute doch stadt und der mensch ist
wo mich der die rinne gewählte wenig
vergessen also schauen oft zeichnet for
business thema co wir sind ja auch in
mussum jetzt dauert das heißt wir
brauchen eigentlich der in richtung im
jetzt wieder schaffen es hat er zwar
klavier wird so genannte im ruhestand
irgend eins mit der natur zähler
das ist bedeutet vereinte durch den die
musik legato also spielt immer schön
soundteppich ist immer da uns andere ist
nur spät nur wenn nötig und mit
bewegungsmelder ist also staccato ist da
und hört wieder auf und so
die beiden 34 hanimann patente papa ist
der garten schläger doppel das ist
eigentlich meine erinnerung wir die
präsenz akustische mit zugewinnen von
ihrem papa erklärt haben dass erster
kartheuser der kunde das könne ja nicht
nachvollziehen das ist natürlich auch
eine interpretation ohne jetzt nicht so
ernst genommen haben wir haben das
einfach mehr das war der unterschied und
von denen beide elternteile grün um
realismus in rechlin teil seiner
erinnerungen und der gott habe oft um
groß was ist das wichtigste zum schluss
entscheidende oder das bild der
akustischen raum soll mitte rolle
spielen da aber der innere an trainer
ist nicht nur akustisch eher visueller
diese geprägt
[Musik]
kürzlich sorgte der verkauf eines
digitalen kunstwerks für schlagzeilen 69
millionen dollar für eine grafik der
clou daran erst eine bestimmte
technologie macht sie so einzigartig
diese technologie heißt ein ft nun von
jbl token und basiert auf der blog chain
technologie und letzte woche kam eines
der ersten fts unter den hammer
diese 24 auf 24 pixel kleinen digitale
grafiken wurden letzte woche bei
christie's versteigert
die sogenannten kripo punks waren heiß
begehrt
[Musik]
die bilder wechselten für fast 17
millionen dollar den besitzer
dabei wurden nur neun der insgesamt
10.000 kripo punks versteigert die
beiden erfinder matt hall und jbod
konsens ließen einen algorithmus die
porträts erstellen jedes porträt hat
andere merkmale sonnenbrille hut oder
pfeife nicht alle merkmale kommen dabei
gleich häufig vor
was zu einem regen handel im internet
führte am seltensten und heute
dementsprechend teuer sind die punks mit
blauer haut 2017 als alles begann konnte
man sich die punks einfach gratis
herunterladen
wir waren uns nicht sicher ist es eher
einfach zum sammeln oder doch eher kunst
wir versuchten einen mittelweg zu gehen
es ist eine limitierte anzahl und doch
gibt es seltene stücke darin
der schweizer galerist und crypto
experte georg back war einer der ersten
die sich für den handel mit den punks
begeisterten die technologie wo sie
vorher apparates ganz spielerische
element und dass sie quasi so ein
kunstwerk schaffen hand praktizieren
also ist ein unikat an handle auf ihre
plattform
ja das ist schon sehr einzigartig neues
sie als erster überhaupt organisierte
back 2018 eine ausstellung der kripo
punks in einer galerie
[Musik]
dafür wurden die digitalen bilder noch
gedruckt
[Musik]
das ist jetzt ein physischer güter frank
damals wurde die künstlich eine client
kann einmal besprochen dass mein buch
stell ich möchte in zürich
und ich habe sie gefragt ob sie eine
idee hat wie ich hatte mit ihm
eigentlich digitale welt mal aussteller
und er nennt sie seine physische print
gemacht die gesetzte nummer von peter
bank unterzeichnet von jenson zugang zum
eigentlichen digitalen werk erhielten
die käufer mit einem versiegelten code
die preise damals um die 50 franken
es war der versuch den kunstsammler an
die digitale welt heran zu führen
[Musik]
doch spätestens seit bibel und seinem
rekord verkauf des bildes airways für 69
millionen dollar kann dank der nfc
technologie jedes elektronische bild ein
unikat sein und gleich behandelt werden
wie physische kunst auch in derselben
auktion von christie's letzter woche
wurden auch bilder von gerhard richter
und banksy verkauft und erzielten
gemeinsam eine kleinere summe als die
krypto punks übernimmt jetzt die
digitale kunst den kunstmarkt besondere
werk innerhalb der der nfc werke im
dialog mit anderen werken des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts mit
herausragenden beispielen zu kombinieren
das 21 jahrhundert ist geprägt von
unterschiedlichsten künstlerischen
strömungen und da bilden die dns einfach
einen interessanten beitrag zu dieser
thematik die krypto punks haben sicher
ihre bedeutung weil sie die ersten ganz
frühen nft kunstwerke sind
inzwischen gibt es einige mehr ob sie
unser kunstverständnis nachhaltig prägen
wird sich zu rücken
was den inhalt der mft sun geht und den
künstlerischen wert bewegen wir uns
eigentlich zum beginn einer reise und
einer entwicklung die die gerade
stattfindet die kanonisierung also was
ist künstlerisch relevant und was ist
vielleicht auch weniger relevant diese
diskussion findet gerade erst statt
es ist also wirklich nicht abzusehen
wohin die reise geht sage jetzt mal nfc
im auge meine größte schockmoment für
kunstvereine für die größte revolution
also meiner mutter die schon damals ist
marginal ausgestellt das ist natürlich
ein affront kunst wird und man hat es
kann richtig verstanden aber es ist
nämlich selber wichtig sie sondern
eigentlich ist es behinderte oder was
was zählt und das sehe ich genauso
für die krypto band geht die reise
zunächst mal ins nächste auktionshaus im
juni versteigert sotheby's die nummer 7
1523 an alien in der kunstwelt
vielleicht schon bald eine
selbstverständlichkeit das spiel mit
licht und schatten schotte hat die
hauptrolle oder hauptrolle im werk du
nimmst dir auf das schauen was hat das
für sie heißt er schaffte in der
namensstreit um neuer aber am ohne das
zu sagen dass auch immer schon so gern
beruft also einer sitze ist natürlich
scott explizit in der ausstellung die
zweite und dritte dimension also so wie
jetzt die zeichnete katze wo in bronze
guss sind wollen die dritte dimension
kümmert oder eben ein stuhl wo im
ruhestand aber die sprachen der wandern
wird ergänzt durch ein schatten wohl
projiziert ist es geht mir eigentlich
extrem um die dimensionen wechsel oder
um das vorzeitige die dritte und die
spieler dem es oft trifft verzeichnet in
rom grund unter schaffte aber offen wann
das licht in der mendener ich verdammt
für die zweite dimension es geht eingang
wo du da auch inszeniert sehr prominent
ein wunderschöner garten auch immer
handtasche ja das ist sprecher des im
mai fällt das ist viel content bzw
ein ort wo meine mama - als logisch wenn
man in amerika konnte
und die haben für mich extrem eleganten
bin das anfangsniveau filme und sich
immer noch so lang am 19
das ist so der ort wo nini macarena
dezente wichtiger moment in der kindheit
gespielt und inszeniert als unendlich
[Musik]
wirtschaften unheimliches rodheim auch
drin steckt ihm ruhm hast du als kind in
den vielen orten konnten immer die
keller gehe und dass das ist schon so
schimek seit margot tief in den keller
und wenn man ein kreativer der musik
also wichtig seien darum ihren immer ppv
hüttner wenn intel mehr familien chemie
mama sitzt wichtig und logis hofs im
hintersten dunkle ecke vorstellung sitz
der gorilla ist das für was steht dafür
das tier in dir und mir einer von den
vielen orten konnten ist in grafing
dream ist sie eine der schwierigsten zu
machen ließ dorf und aleppo mit hartmann
und stoffen kreis ein handwerker und
haben großen hunger immer unter das
stecke sich zurück zur rückserie
einstellungs- und das ist eigentlich der
ort wo der favorit
hingehören wo er ist also die idee von
großer unheimlicher wo gleichzeitig aus
ängstlicher ist oder das ruhige mitte
sitzt wahrscheinlich sogar so weit zu
sagen schweizer pipilotti rist lud
fertig menstruationsblut die volle
dröhnung und erzähler leutenecker die
fini strich die stille gäste ja ich
glaube wenn es mit ihnen gibt gibt es
nicht wir am sie hat mir natürlich auch
ein welt bereitet oder sich wichtig auf
und wenn man kunst wurde nimmt
videokunst bewegte bild die
selbstverständlichkeit wie sie geschafft
hat immer und wie sie wirkt die präsenz
was ich glaube nicht dass das jetzt
unbedingt gegen hans kessler sondern
mitten am pc wie sich sie einfach auf
einer wichtigen wegbereiter ja wie wird
man künstlerin künstler klar auch dafür
gibt es ausbildungsstätten zb die ff
schule für kunst und design in zürich
und jetzt ist es genau 50 jahre her seit
sie sich abgespalten hat in einer
revolte von der zürcher hochschule der
künste
[Musik]
so sieht revolte aus 1969 eine
experimental klasse der
kunstgewerbeschule zürich übt
spielerische kreativität und teamwork
die schulleitung will das bunte treiben
unterbinden doch die betroffenen wehren
sich rebellion stimmung an der
kunstgewerbeschule zürich sechs lehrer
demissionierten ihre schüler
solidarisierten sich mit ihnen die
jungen forderten den rücktritt des
direktors
vergeblich die experimental klasse form
und farbe kurz f&f wird aufgelöst
[Applaus]
doch die abgesprungene lehrerschaft
gründet im selben jahr ihre eigene
private f&f schule für experimentelle
gestaltung
[Musik]
50 jahre ist das her grund genug für
eine jubiläums ausstellung in der
kunsthalle zürich
im rückblick war diese abspaltung
unvermeidlich erinnert sich mitgründer
peter jany hätte die spritze spiel du
für dich dann der fertigkeit freut
flache wichtige worte aus note
das müsste zum konflikt um nachträglich
betrachtet ist für mich der konflikt
richtiger glücksfall
die mitgründerin und feministische
aktivistin tourist stauffer formulierte
es so im kurs tiefergelegt und galle
wir möchten unsere 15 witze mehr finde
mir spiele und richter die ist praxis
und ihre kunst als forschungsfeld für
freies und kollektives experimentieren
die neue ff schule findet schnell zu
laufen
aktionskunst performance und film video
mit neuen kunstrichtungen profitiert man
sich nirgendwo sonst in der schweiz
können die studierenden den unterricht
so frei mitbestimmen
um ihre kreativen talente auszubilden
michael hiltbrunner arbeitet geschichte
und archiv der ff schule auf er weiß
experimentieren traf den zeitgeist
damals galt sie hält ihr als drucker und
altmodisch wort noch gar kein bitteres
von der ffc werberings ganz
verschiedener ort auch um den pc
einige erfolgreiche kunstschaffende
haben an der ff angefangen walter
pfeiffer heute gefragt der mode fotograf
und musiker stephan eicher der über
seine zeit an der ff verlauten lässt
[Musik]
genazinos bild dpa erst machte er küsst
sie mitstreiter branik k
wie das geld auch die malerin barbara
hat die f&f schule besucht in den
bewegten frühen 80er jahren mit an die
damen aus melle
die salbe betrügerische identitäten
karriere wie sie politische anliegen
auch im künstlerischen prozess
integrieren
und da muss man aufgaben wie im labor
forschen experimentieren und eigentlich
dass das tolle xia
das meine ich alle medien ausprobiere
und gleichzeitig hat aber viel input
über experimente unter anleitung von
profis das gilt bis heute hier mit eva
hurley einer pionieren in sachen
performance und körper kommunikation
sie begann vor 40 jahren kurse an der
f&f zu leiten
mit wehmut erinnerte sich an die große
freiheit die auch die lehrer innen
damals genossen das ist heute anders
der druck auf die kunstschulen ist
gestiegen und doch bleibt die f und f
eine ausnahme machen
[Musik]
ja das war unsere reise im zehnerfeld
hier im bündner kunstmuseum in chur
wenn sie selber kommen möchten uns
schauen die ausstellung läuft bis zum
ersten august der nächste woche da
machen wir in murten station und
besuchen den 14-jährigen leonard riesen
er ist museumsdirektor und ein echter
experte
hier geht's gleich weiter mit der
dänischen serie die wege des herrn
kommen sie gut durch die woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos